you have been doing some really cool
stuff the last few years have you been
able to like sort of take a step back
and be like oh my God like look what I'm
doing
um no this is it it takes someone
telling me uh that someone had said that
uh someone's like yeah you just did
after party and Sonic and this and I was
like yeah I guess those are very
different That's so exciting but it
takes someone to I'm getting better as I
get older too I'm always worried about
what's next and I very rarely uh take
the time but I've been way better at
when something happens to be like I'm
really happy I'm really proud I was
really proud of the after party and it
took my moment with that or like Sonic 2
doing so well was like how exciting is
that so like with this I'm so excited to
do something totally different like when
you and I are talking it's rarely about
something this gory or you know me doing
fight scenes or me wielding guns and
trying to kill people so for me
um this is very exciting Steve you have
tattoos and stuff you have a different
look and
oh 100 and if I had that those tattoos
and that outfit I would abs and looking
like you without that stuff I would
absolutely want to leave set and just go
out with it and I did and that's what I
want to know what was how did you get
treated when you went out with all that
stuff it was so funny some people were
like because there's a lot of tattoos if
I wore a short sleeve shirt you'd see
they go all the way up literally all the
way up and around my chest it was like
connected Christian Tinsley and Corrine
put them on uh the gentleman who created
the way that we do these tattoos is
called Tinsley transfers so Christian
Tinsley that gentleman was the person
who put him on in created him which is
great
um but um I would wear them on like in
the elevator arm in the hotel and then
going to get food there's a place like
in New Orleans that I went a bunch to
get breakfast at the same place every
day and um you could see that people
look at you a little bit different some
people are like like this and then other
people are like oh very cool like some
people want to connect with you about
the tattoos because they're sleet it's a
choice I'm making it's not like one
little thing that says like hope it's
like it's like a but if they look if you
look close enough tattoos they're all
like
terrible they're like guns and like
werewolves yelling at each other and
like drugs and eight balls and so if you
look closely at people so from afar be
like oh like oh man what is this guy
into what is he doing yeah a lot of bad
life choices right did you have any
input on the tattoos yeah they gave me a
bunch of they gave me a bunch of things
and then I got to like you know every
now and then I'm like oh what if we did
this or what if we change this to this
or if instead of this name let's have it
this name or you know stuff like that so
I got to play with that a little bit uh
I can't imagine I know you're a movie
fan and I'm usually a fan and I can't
imagine what it was like your first day
on set with Nick oh my God and then I
really have to as Dracula yes so it's
not even just Nick Cage it's I'm in
front of Nick Cage as Dracula which is
bananas it's like two worlds two Idols
clashing to become one super Idol super
id'll be a good TV show we could
probably write don't you think
um a hundred percent I don't know if
American Idol will not Sue you right but
there's a chance we'll see it's super
adult so different right so I but so I
know you're a fan in a cage what how
many days did it take before you started
getting geeky with him asking them some
questions first day over literally for
the same with Jim Carrey I wrote about
Jim Carrey first day I asked about ice
Ventura it was there was no because I
was like I don't know I'm never gonna be
near this person again so first day
talking to him about stuff and talking
about movies and talking about things he
likes I'm always interested in like the
people that I'm watching and stuff I'm
always interested in what they're
watching
um or like unique experiences or we'll
just talk about somebody and I'd be like
all right yeah that's my close friend
for this many years like all right
you've been doing this forever you know
everybody you've encountered everybody
so it's just it's great he's a museum of
knowledge it's amazing what actually
surprised you about working with him in
his process us on set yes he was so
committed he was so committed and he was
there on time every day sometimes people
that are big stars they feel like they
can play the system a little bit and get
there at the last second he was so
prepared game for anything when I
improvised with him he was totally down
and excited to improvise he would get
himself when he's supposed to be
dragging angry get himself angry right
before and then someone say action then
you come into the scene so it was it was
everything I hoped like uh one of those
like Hollywood icons would be what did
you borrow of his costume because I know
you wouldn't that's the most important
man I didn't get to keep anything
costume wise my costume was bananas and
his costume like to have that Cape or I
mean he looks incredible he has so many
different looks in this thing it's
amazing uh you got to participate in
some of the action
um yes and did it look believable yeah
no 100 right but you should thank the
editor right yeah oh there couldn't have
been me jumping off of a balcony no but
like uh one of the things that I was
really surprised at in the movie and I
wasn't sure going in like how much
action there would be would there be
blood like I really didn't know and
there was a ton of blood
and I guess it was all done probably the
second president told me Kevin
McCarthy's like there's a lot of blood
in this yeah yeah oh I was all in I love
that kind of stuff when it's just over
the top and it's yeah so what was it
like on set because people don't realize
when you have that much blood and you're
doing it practically when you reset it
takes a while and you got the worst and
also there's scenes where you're
coughing up blood all over yourself now
that's a change of your outfit or like
the whole your whole face is bloody then
they got to reset or if it's getting
shot with squibs you have to do that
then you have to reset everything and
put new bullets in you know not bullets
obviously but the scribs and new outfits
so for me not doing action movies ever
this was like a whole new thing for me
to learn same with like the after party
learn choreography and singing like that
was all new so it's so fun to like learn
different things and also see like the
Michael Jordan of everybody's field so
like Chris Brewster is like one of the
best stunt coordinators in the universe
and then so to work with him and stuff
like that it's really fun to learn and
then I've spent a lot of time with that
stunt team because I was in New Orleans
a lot so I'd hang out with all the guys
and Marvin Ross is in this who's like
they're just awesome people there so
you're just learning I just I love
learning about everything because it
feels so lucky to be making movies doing
action is time consuming
um is it something that after doing this
you are more excited to do action or
were you like this was a little more it
would have to be worth it it would
because you're right because first of
all it's I had to get in shape a little
bit so I can do the stuff and then
um I had to learn the correct so I'm
here like three weeks earlier than I
would ever be in a movie to do all the
choreography to learn it to train and
all that stuff and so
um I would have to the the action would
have to be worth it it would have to be
cool or the movie that'd be awesome if
it's just like I was like oh it's not
worth it but if it's like so cool I mean
it was Heaven it was when you see what
it looks like I really got to do a lot
of stuff I was on wires I was getting
pulled I was getting punched I was
throwing real punches and stuff like
that so it's like I loved all of it but
you're right if the movie's like damn we
don't need to do this you know what I
mean it's a lot of work and the people
who are stumbling they're really good
are like some men and women obviously
are
extraordinary they're so incredible it's
incredible uh before I run out of time
with you have you started recording on
Sonic 3 yet no I haven't done anything
yet I I haven't done anything
have you been told anything about it no
I hope that I get to do this movie well
it comes out next year I'm confident
that a year and a half but I hope I'm I
hope I get to do it I'm I'm pretty
confident they're not making it without
your voice that would be nice you know
that would be great but I am the thing
that I'm really curious about is Jim has
said that he is close to retiring no I
was I was uh doing press with him last
time when uh that came out while we were
doing press yeah um I hope he doesn't
retire because he's I love Jim Carrey I
think I can't imagine a world where
we're watching films and Jim Carrey's in
them but I understand him and like the
idea of him being like you know what
I've done so much already that maybe you
know he deserves to do whatever he wants
but
um my comedic heart I was like man it's
too fun to see him as Robotnik so I hope
he comes back I hope we all get to come
back I think that he is as you said he
should do whatever the hell makes him
happy but the thing I know because he's
talked about it is he gives so much when
he's on set to every role that he does
including you know Sonic so it's like
I'm so curious is he gonna do it or not
because he's such a big part it would be
be wonderful if in the next couple
months we saw an article that said all
of us are coming back that would make me
very very happy so let's cross our
fingers and hope so because how fun
Sonic 3 with all these guys and then we
have Shadow come on listen 100
um I hope he's there that'd be that'd be
it would make me sad if Jim Carrey
wasn't there I have to ask does does
Jasper make an appearance in after party
season two that's a great question I
mean how could he he's in he would have
to be in jail but that doesn't stop
anybody I guessed uh you're right if I
guess if there's a scene with the
specific the specifics of the way it
would have to happen are so specific
that it'd be very hard I'm very excited
to see if I'm in the second season this
much is certain I'm not in it a lot or
at all right listen I'm just I'm fishing
you know yeah just seeing but listen I
know that you have Die Hard season two
which yes and Radio City Musical I'm
playing Radio City Music Hall in New
York in September my improv show and die
hard is me Kevin Hart John Cena a
Natalie Manuel Paul Appel it's really
funny and that comes out on Roku it's
crazy because right now all my stuff
seems to be coming out at the same time
all my stuff for some reason everything
times out where it's like batches of
stuff whereas after party space force
and Sonic and now it's a die-hard
Renfield and we lost our humans which
was a a Netflix interactive Choose Your
Own Adventure thing but um diehardt's
really fun and Kevin Hart's it's in he's
like a machine it's unbelie I've never
seen one human being do so many things
in my entire life and do them at the
level that he's able to do but the show
is really funny and then uh Ben Schwartz
and friends rejectedjokes.com you can
buy tickets there what is it like I
don't know if you've played Radio City
before but what does that actually no
improviser has ever played Radio City
Music Hall supposedly that's what Radio
City told me I don't know if that's true
but Radio City said I would be the first
ever improv show that's playing that
venue so I want I really want to know
when you're doing something like that
and you're playing at a venue that is so
historic iconic world famous how much
like are you right now even though it's
improv yeah how much are you sort of
thinking maybe I need to have a few
things in my head no never you can't go
in with anything the whole idea is I got
this far without anything like we just
go we go in there with nothing and we
create on the spot the only thing that
it is is uh it's I don't get nervous on
tours but when I play Carnegie Hall uh I
did The Beacon Theater which you came to
twice and or and um Radio City Radio
City I'll be a little bit nervous
beforehand just because it's so big it's
6 000 people it's by far the biggest
crowd I've Done 3 600 but I'm so it's
like excited but I'm just I'm nervous
I'm so excited I can't wait to see if it
works nobody's ever tried a venue that
big so it's like I can't wait to see if
it's where I think nobody ever I don't
know the real facts but
um so the obviously nothing planned
beforehand but it's bananas when like
you go backstage and it's like 100
dressing rooms for like rockets but it's
just us me and my three friends in a
small room being like all right so let's
have a good show and uh you know what I
mean we're so like Bare Bones the whole
thing
um but I'm really excited Ben Schwartz
and friends we're now it's been a tour
will already be announced by this time
this comes out and then I don't know
what I'm gonna speak to you next which
is a bummer you and I usually speak a
lot well you can attend some of my
screenings right of course you know just
throwing that out there yeah on that
note I'm going to say congrats on this I
really hope it's a huge hit thank you
man I'd love to keep playing bad guys
those are very fun